let's head to our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes and Deborah I
understand that you've got some breaking
news about the operation
yes so I understand that the the
aircraft the Royal Air Force aircraft
that were involved in this high-risk
evacuation mission of British diplomats
from the Sudanese Capital have arrived
back in uh Cyprus a military a British
Air Base in Cyprus RAF aquateri
um they were involved in this operation
that we've been talking about over the
last few hours and I can also reveal
some details about this significant
mission that was mounted to rescue
British diplomats and it was mounted in
coordination with other countries and
particularly the night the United States
and the French both of their armed
forces have also been operating over the
weekend bringing out their diplomats
they've had to have permission from the
Sudanese military to be able to land
their aircraft and get their people out
I understand that from the UK side the
mission started with a small team of
British troops who flew in under cover
of Darkness late on Saturday on one of
the American aircraft that was involved
involved in the U.S evacuation effort
and then that team sort of peeled off
and went towards the compound in
Khartoum where um the British or the
area sorry of the city where the British
Embassy is located and
um this small number of British
diplomats as well as their families and
making sure that they were assembled
together and then working out how best
to get them out and in tandem with that
leg of the operation it's clearly
incredibly complicated because
um Khartoum is an active conflict Zone
you had these two British military
aircraft that had taken off from Cyprus
from RAF that criteria I understand it
was a C-130 transport plane and an a400m
Airbus transport plane these two
aircraft landed in an Airfield just
north of the capital with permission
from the Sudanese military to land the
French had also been using that Airfield
and they landed there around early hours
of the morning around one o'clock UK
time give or take and then the decision
had to be taken about how to get this
team of British diplomats that needed to
be accurate evacuated to this Airfield
complicating matters is the fact that
the the British Embassy the area where
it is it's kind of almost in the middle
of the the two warring factions these
rival generals that have turned Khartoum
into a war zone over the last week and a
half it was decided that um it's about
30 kilometers in terms of the roots and
there are many checkpoints and of course
you can imagine a lot of military
planning went on for the different kinds
of contingencies I understand that there
was additional forces that could have
been deployed in if there was active
fighting going on and in that sort of
scenario
um the British would have had to really
kind of fight their way to this team and
and enable them to evacuate in the event
though
um the the British team decided it was
okay to be able to move them to this
Airfield I understand a unit that had
flown in with the two British aircraft
also kind of drove out to meet them
um then they boarded these planes these
two planes and took off and have now
um safely landed in Cyprus after what
must have been an incredibly traumatic
time but of course as you said many
British Nationals still in cartoon still
wondering what will happen to them